five six seven eight oh yeah
Kylie Jenner's living it up in the air
with her daughter and nieces I love it
TV Mogul shared this video from her
private jet featuring her five-year-old
stormy sister Kim's daughter shy and
brother Rob's daughter dream okay
signs up everyone I am interviewing the
girls
oh this move is crazy I'm interviewing
the girls for my Tick Tock okay get
together
yeah Kylie gets into reporter mode to
ask the girls these very important
questions what is
you're everyone's favorite color
um mine is
pink and blue
mine is pink and blue
blue and white
sure the mom of two only got one
question in but the little ones are busy
having a good time
[Music]
the only one missing from the
Kardashians youngest daughters Chloe's
little girl true I am so obsessed with
her and I love it so much but true
didn't miss out on this recent outing a
girls movie night with her cousins
hosted by her mama you guys I'm so
excited
we have a private screening for the new
Little Mermaid
and I'm so excited for all the kids hi
guys
look at all this stuff how great hi guys
yep it was an over-the-top screening of
Disney's newest movie The Little Mermaid
and the little ones felt like they were
a part of their
look at this stuff isn't it neat
wouldn't you think my collection's
complete wouldn't you think I'm the girl
the girl who has everything
the girls screamed too Coco says it was
a moment she wished she caught on camera
it's been such a beautiful moment for me
to be able to see the reactions of the
babies it makes me just emotionally
overwhelmed honestly and I cry as soon
as I watch them because I think of the
little girl that's still in me honestly
and it heals that girl inside of me one
thing's for sure the famous sisters
would do anything for their babies my
favorite part about being a mom I mean
it's so corny but it's just like no
matter how tired you are whatever you
just it's complete Bliss I think after
having kids it just is such a life
changer or a life is so different I feel
like this is when life really
begins and it's been so much fun to be
on this journey and we're so here for
the Journey of the family's next
generation five six seven eight
oh yeah
[Music]